Now that you've worked with constructors a little bit, let's do an example of
constructing some rectangles. We want to initialize the variables box, and
box2, with two rectangles of equal dimensions that touch each other at a
corner. I'm going to give you a few more specifications. I want box to have a
width of 20 and a height of 30. I want box's top left pixel to be at x is 60,
and y is 90. And if this is the frist box, I want box2 to touch it at this
bottom right corner. Boot up BlueJ and try this for yourself. Then paste the
code for the two boxes into the editor that we give you. Don't worry if too
much if BlueJ isn't working, you can just the Audacity editor we're providing.
And here's a quick hint, if you find that your boxes aren't showing up, it
might be because you have to remember to call the draw method.